is a significant moment in the history
of Manchester United a formal bid has
now been submitted for the club to end
the ownership of the glazers and it has
come from the chairman of the Qatar
Islamic Bank and it is Sheikh jasim bin
Hamad al-thani and this is something
that Sky News has been revealing
throughout the day the fact his father
the former Qatari prime minister was
involved in putting together this bid
his father Sheikh Hammer been jasim
known as hbj he has a lot of Investments
already in London in Connaught hotels in
property around Hyde Park very notable
investment figure and Sky News revealed
that earlier today his involvement in
this bid and we do have a statement from
the bidders now it says Sheikh jasim bin
Hamad al-thani today confirmed his
submission for a bid for 100 of
Manchester United Football Club that's
his father you're seeing on the screen
now the bid plans to return the club to
its former glories both on and off the
pitch and above all will seek to place
the fans at the heart of Manchester
United Football Club Once More the bid
will be completely debt free via Shake
Jason's 9-2 Foundation which will look
to invest in the football teams the
training center the stadium and The
Wider infrastructure The Fan Experience
and the communities the club supports
the statement goes on the vision of the
bid is for Manchester United Football
Club to be renowned for footballing
excellence and regarded as the greatest
football club in the world more details
of the bid will be released when
appropriate if and when the bid process
develops now some details on Sheikh
jasim he was educated here in Britain at
the Sandhurst rural Military Academy he
graduated as an officer Cadet and he's
been chairman of qib one of the main
banks in Qatar as well as having board
roles other clubs he's born in 1982
we're told he's a lifelong Manchester
United fan and
you know he above all it's all about
trying to regain the glories of
Manchester United Football Club it was
in November that the owning Glazer
family announced they were going to put
the club up for sale open to outside
investment at the club they've owned
since 2005 a period marked by Van
descent over the debt they loaded onto
the club and indeed the under investment
as they see it in recent years not only
in the squad but the stadium as they've
gone 10 years without winning the
Premier League title and since the
glazes have owned Manchester United
they've seen other clubs come under golf
ownership here Abu Dhabi with Manchester
City who've won six Premier League
titles in the last 11 years Newcastle
United more recently with Saudi
ownership through their Sovereign wealth
fund Paris and German have Qatari
ownership through the Qatar Sovereign
wealth fund and this bid is clearly for
Manchester United being positioned as
separate from a state entity the fact
it's through the qib chair although many
of the cash flows do ultimately flow
back to the Emira Qatar in this very
wealthy country and the reason to keep
it separate or to be normally separate
is because you wait for regulations
European football rules do prevent two
clubs controlled by the same investors
normally coming up against each other in
competitions like the Champions League
the reason
let's talk about the other bids as well
so Jim Ratcliffe of course a lifelong
Manchester United supporter had said
that he too might put in a bid I'm not
sure if we we know of a formal bid yet
before that 10 pm deadline but if sir
Jim Ratcliffe doesn't get it as well
then that means there are a lot of
Premier League clubs owned by uh
countries outside of the UK
yeah already more than half of the
Premier League clubs are owned by
International investors really a
reflection of the Premier League's
International appeal with overseas
television income including from Comcast
the owners of Sky News Now exceeding
that from their domestic broadcasters
like sky so it's a sign of that
International growth and we are waiting
to see just what happens ahead of this
10 p.m deadline that the rain group The
Investment Bank lead in the search for
investment for the Glazer family set
which bids come in by then the first
declared bid was from Sir Jim Radcliffe
the chairman of ineos the petrochemical
Giants a lifelong Manchester United fan
himself that was almost a month or so
ago he announced his interest we've
heard nothing today ahead of that
deadline whether a bid has been put in
and perhaps a lot will of course come
down to the price but the largest bid
will be the one we'd expect the glazers
might take if they choose to accept if
the price is right because there is no
figure on this bid from the Qatari end
of things and I'm told that they're only
now able to perhaps get full access to
some of the books of the club to
actually get a sense what the club might
be worth but certainly the sense is it
to take a bit of more than 5 billion
pounds perhaps to get control of
Manchester United